[Musique]
josé mirande bonjour oui bonjour
candidats aux élections municipales aux
marins incontestablement le prochain
scrutin dans cette ville sera
particulier compte tenu de la situation
judiciaire actuel du maire qui ne se
représente pas certes mais ce qui met
une singulière effervescence dans la
ville estimez-vous josé mirande que ce
contexte puisse vous être
particulièrement favorable émise à part
ça quelles sont les motivations qui vous
ont poussé à être candidat une fois de
plus il fallait aussi bien le dire non
c'est pas un contexte qui nous est
favorable du tout nous avons un maire
qui reste et compte sept ans va faire
c'est aux métaux qu'il est là et il a
une cote d'amour de la population donc
si vraiment pas une situation qui
favorable franchement nous parlons de
rodolphe désiré je vous dis c'est sa 9e
n'arrange rien du tout et ça m'empêche
pas de continuer le travail que j'ai
commencé depuis très longtemps
ma motivation est un mot qui vous
revient engagement un engagement pour ma
ville depuis très longtemps au service
de la vie associative bien sûr et
politique aussi et depuis 20 ans avec un
groupe de femmes et d'hommes
nous avons proposé une alternative mais
je précise par le haut de notre ville et
en mettant à profit nos expériences nos
compétences pour mieux vivre ensemble
mais aussi l'amour que j'ai pour cette
ville et vous avez quand on aime on ne
compte pas c'est vous ça que je ne
compte pas depuis beaucoup d'années
cette motivation passe aussi par
beaucoup de sujets la sécurité
l'environnement les équipements sa noble
chose on va y revenir venir simplement
cette motivation passe pas envie de
faire tout ça tout à fait très bien
alors vous josemi rendez vos colistiers
de dynamique marinoise si vous êtes élu
en mars prochain
une fois arrivé donc
au sein de la municipalité quel serait
votre dossier le plus urgent votre
priorité
alors vous savez je serai peut-être
original je vais pas faire comme tout le
monde nous avons un projet après des
centaines et des centaines de rien
cacher j'ai eu le temps vraiment en fait
ils à bord et un projet après nos
échanges nous partage avec cette
population nous avons nous avons amené à
demander au fil du temps mais est ce que
pour vous la municipalité marinoise
devra faire face à une difficulté
particulière compte tenu du du bilan
confins de la situation vous savez j'ai
évité des serait bien moi je dis
je les dis le 26 octobre à la patine
scola du marin je prends l'héritage en
l'état l'héritage comprend peut-être un
peu manque de trésorerie delà des
déficits le personnel les
recommandations de la chambre viol de
compte etc etc je prends nous prenons
avec l'équipe de dean maïwenn les
visages en état et nous ferons ce que
nous devons faire pour donner des
satisfactions marée noire voilà notre
engagement
maintenant je vais vraiment pas passer
mon temps à dire ce qui ne s'est pas
fait dans le passé je veux plus passer à
montady que je projette de faire et il
n'y a pas une priorité
il ya un ensemble de choses à faire
c'est ça qui est important l'ensemble
des choses a fait s'articule autour de
quatre axes majeurs que nous avons
clairement définis dans notre projet que
vous veniez avec des chantiers
prioritaires et dans ses chantiers
prioritaires il y en a qui nous tiennent
beaucoup à coeur et qui ne coûte rien
surtout le chantier
la proximité de la cohésion sociale ça
ne coûte pas s'en cacher d'autres
beaucoup diront que il a un projet oui
on l'a dit et c'est distribué dans
toutes les boîtes aux lettres de la
ville du marin on a ce projet là mais le
chiffre est de se poser a été fait en
amont pour nous permettre de dire sur
les douze prochaines années nous
pourrons mettre en oeuvre ce projet avec
notre capacité financière puisque la
chambre régionale de coach prévart aux
toiles et qu'il est financier en 2021 ce
que nous prévoyons aussi pour conclure
alors justement sur votre profession de
foi à laquelle vous avez fait allusion
gelé sous les yeux il ya un slogan le
marin entre terre et mer
alors est ce que cela signifie que à vos
yeux on a peut-être davantage
privilégier un type de développement qu
un autre on nous c'est un peu trop
tournée vers la mer est un peu moins
vers les campagnes équilibré tout ça
peut-être fait c'est une question ce
n'est pas un slogan sur le titre de
notre projet le marin entre terry mais
je vous dis une chose le marin s'est pas
construit d'hyères quand il s'est
construit il ya plus de siècle gâcha 30
secondes à peine
ouais chacun a fait de son temps ce
qu'il devait faire l'équipe en place a
tourné le monde veut la mer ça nous de
faire notre mission qui est entre terre
et mer à porter une composante terrestre
à la halle à l'épanouissement des mains
d'emma rhinois merci jose miranda
ah oui c'est les 5 minutes sont écoulées
ça y est ça pas très bien merci vous
faisiez
[Musique]